- Welcome everybody to the seminar today.
It's a pleasure to welcome Marshall Burke,
who is an associate professor
in the Department of Earth System Science
at Stanford University,
where he is also a deputy director
at the Center on Food
Security and the Environment.
Marshall's research focuses
on social and economic impacts
of environmental change,
and on measuring and understanding
economic livelihoods across
the developing world.
I tend to think of Marshall's work
as focusing on big
questions using big data,
using empirical methods that
are very carefully executed.
And one of the interesting
things about Marshall's research
is that he publishes both in economics
and scientific journals,
and he holds a PhD in
agricultural resource economics
from the University of
California, Berkeley.
It's a pleasure to welcome him here today,
he's gonna be speaking
to us on understanding
the causal impacts of
climate on human conflict.
And before I turn it over to
Marshall to start his seminar,
I'll just say that he welcomes
questions or interruptions,
clarifications or comments
throughout the seminar.
You're welcome to just
raise your hand feature,
and he'll either see it and respond,
or I'll just give him a little nudge
to focus on your questions
and keep on with his presentation.
So without any further
introduction, welcome Marshall
and we look forward to your presentation.
- Great. Thanks a lot, Matt.
And thank you guys for having me,
too bad couldn't make it in person,
hopefully sometime in the future,
but thanks a lot for coming
on what I hear is a very rainy,
blustery day in New Haven.
So let me share some slides.
Yeah, so as Matt said,
this is very much work in progress
and would love to get your feedback
and your comments and
questions at any point.
So please do jump in and interrupt.
It might be hard for
me to see the hands up,
so please be aggressive in intervening.
I'll try to also leave
some time at the end
for additional questions and conversation.
Cause I think there's a lot of
ways we could take this work.
So as Matt said, this
is going to be a talk,
and again, really work in progress,
where we are trying to
take a big picture look
at the relationship
between changes in climate,
broadly construed,
although today we'll focus
mainly on temperature changes,
which are perhaps the best
studied and best observed,
and its potential impacts
on different types of
conflict around the world.
And I'll try to define these
more precisely in a moment,
but we are going to be casting a wide net,
both in terms of how
we think about climate
and in terms of how we
think about conflict.
And we are going to be using data,
as much data as we can assemble,
either on our own or from
existing published studies
to try to characterize
whether there's an overall
relationship on average
and how that relationship
might differ across settings.
And then to use that
backward looking evidence
from recent history,
to try to say something about
what the world might look like
going forward as the climate warms
and as economies hopefully
continue to develop.
So this is joint work with
two Berkeley collaborators,
Ted Miguel, and Sol Hsiang,
three, Joel Ferguson.
So Ted and Sol are on faculty there,
Joel Ferguson is a great graduate student
in RE Department,
and Jerry Min is a RA who works with me,
here at Stanford.
Okay. So if I can advance my slides,
I think I'm speaking to
a crowd that thinks a lot
about conflict and its consequences.
So maybe what my motivation here
will be a little bit
preaching to the choir,
but a lot of people don't
think a lot about conflict,
but they do read Steven
Pinker's popular press books.
These are very popular and
I'm sure many of you have read
this very nice book, "Better
angels of our nature",
subtitle, "Why violence has declined".
And in this book,
Pinker really takes a very long view,
century millennial scale
view on human violence,
and argues, I would
say, fairly persuasively
that over the very long run,
we've seen a pretty remarkable decline
in humans being nasty towards one another,
violent outcomes.
And really what he can study well here
is more individual level conflict.
You know, homicide, basically,
a lot of his evidence comes from homicide,
but also has relevance for
broader group scale conflict.
So a lot of people read
this book and think,
well, conflict is sort of
a thing of the past, right?
Yeah, maybe we still see some,
but it's gone down substantially
and we're much more peaceful than we were
decades, centuries, millennia ago.
That might be true.
But what is also true is if
you look in a more recent era,
we have seen a not monotonic,
not completely steady,
but overall increase in
various types of conflicts.
So I apologize that the X
axis here is hard to read,
the data here go from the
post-war period in 1946 to 2020.
And what you see in the
different colors here
are the number of
conflicts around the world
of various types.
So these have sort of
clinical definitions,
in the darker blue is what's
officially called a civil war.
That is a conflict in which
a thousand people died
and where one of the
combatants is a state.
So think of this as a state,
either fighting another state,
or more typically fighting
some other groups,
some other non-state
actor within the country.
So the wars are the very large one
that kill over a thousand people,
and the lighter colored,
reddish ones here,
are minor ones that lead to
at least 25 battle deaths.
Often these are associated
with many more deaths
beyond just the battle deaths,
but this is how these are counted.
And sort of no matter how you count these,
the number sort of peaked in the mid '90s,
after the end of Cold War
and then declined afterwards,
Steven Pinker wrote his book,
but then in the last decade,
these have come back
up pretty dramatically
and now have reached totals
that exceed what we saw
during the, really, the most
conflictual post-war period,
which was the early '90s in the world.
So now the annual number of
conflicts is at an all time high
post World War II.
So Pinker might be right on the long view,
but in the shorter view,
conflict is certainly not going down,
if anything, it's going up.
You see conflicts around the world,
so this is not just
concentrated in one area.
Here's the map from 2020.
So these are data from the UCDP.
For whatever reason,
the Scandinavians have
really committed themselves
to counting conflicts around the world,
so all our great data
come from different groups
in Norway and Sweden.
This is from the UCDP and
I'll show you various analysis
using the UCDP data.
Here's just a recent figure they put out,
showing where these state-based
conflicts are happening,
really right now.
So this is from last year.
Many of these are ongoing,
and as you can see,
these are pretty widespread
around the world.
They're not just
concentrated in one region.
So conflict is going up,
spread around the world,
we are in a high conflict
period, spread down.
And again, I think for this crew,
this stuff is well known,
but conflict is bad on its own,
but it's also bad because
it worsens many outcomes
that we care about.
So if you think about the
number of forced displacement,
conflict is a leading cause
of forced displacement
around the world,
and no surprises, conflicts have increased
in the last decade.
We've seen a steady increase
in the number of people,
either internally displaced
or crossing borders to escape conflicts.
Again, this is not just conflict driven,
but conflict has been a large driver here.
You can also think of other outcomes,
economic outcomes or
food insecurity outcomes.
So food insecurity or the
prevalence of undernutrition
was on a steady decline for many years,
again, until about a decade ago,
and now is flattened down,
and if anything, is on the rise,
the last year here is
mainly COVID related.
But a lot of this
flattening, I think, again,
can be attributed to the
increase in conflict.
It's reversing the
progress that we've seen
against food insecurity around the world.
Okay. So that's conflict.
So why might climate be
at all relevant here?
Let me motivate this in a couple of ways,
first, by using some
quotes from luminaries
from the recent and distant past.
So here's president Barack
Obama when he got elected
and then immediately won
the Nobel peace prize.
Here's what he said during that speech,
"the world must come together
to confront climate change.
"There is little scientific
dispute that if we do nothing,
"we will face more drought, more famine,
"more mass displacement,
"all of which will fuel
more conflict for decades."
So here is Obama over a decade ago,
making a very strong empirical claim
relating changes in climate
to conflict outcomes.
We can go back further,
if I can advance my slide,
here we go, Romeo and Juliet.
So now we're going back centuries.
If you remember Romeo and Juliet,
roughly there's the good
guys and the bad guys,
here the set of good guys
talking to each other,
Benvolio and Mercutio,
these are good friends of Romeo.
This is midway through Romeo and Juliet.
So they're out in the street
and it's a very hot day.
So, "I pray the good
Mercutio, let's retire."
Let's go inside.
"The day is hot." The
Capulets, the bad guys, abroad,
"and if we meet, we
shall not 'scape a brawl,
"for now these hot days is
the mad blood stirring."
So basically Shakespeare is saying here,
there's just something about it being hot
that causes us to want
to fight each other.
And sure enough, they don't go inside,
all hell breaks loose, many people die.
And so Romeo and Juliet,
and Shakespeare in general,
is typically not read as empirical work
on climate and conflict yet.
I would argue there's
some early evidence here,
in Romeo and Juliet.
Okay. So why might this actually matter?
So if we go back to these
quotes, you can see Obama,
I would say making perhaps
an economic argument
between changes in conditions,
economic conditions,
livelihood conditions on the ground,
and a propensity for conflict.
So that's one potential mechanism
that might link climate and conflict.
So if we think changes in
climate affect livelihoods,
and we think changes in livelihoods
affect the propensity for conflict,
then you could see a natural pathway
from climate to conflict.
Shakespeare is making a
very different argument.
It's not about economic conditions here.
It's just something about
the physiological response to heat.
And I think if we introspect a little bit
and you just think about
how you feel on a hot day,
potentially grumpier,
you might think, can that lead to changes
in certain types of conflict outcomes,
just a physiological response.
And I'll show you some evidence
that actually that might be the case.
So there are multiple mechanisms.
So again, the Obama story is perhaps
about economic conditions,
the Shakespearian story is perhaps about
sort of physiological or
psychological response.
There are other stories,
and again, I'll get to the
literature in a second,
that has looked at this one,
is more a migration story,
so maybe relevant to the research of folks
at the McMillan Center here.
So climate change can drive migration,
there's good empirical evidence of that.
And there are many studies suggesting that
migrants, in various ways,
as they come into new areas,
can perhaps precipitate conflict
with people in the receiving location.
Another long-term story
is about grievances,
so perhaps changes in climate can amplify
or multiply existing
grievances between groups,
as they alter, again, economic
conditions on the ground.
So that's yet another story
why climate might matter for conflict.
Differentiating these stories
is something we're gonna
try to do in this work,
and I'll get back to that towards the end.
Okay.
I wanna emphasize from the very beginning
that we are not environmental
determinists here,
nothing we're going to study empirically
links between changes
in climate and conflict.
None of this should argue
that climate is the only,
nor the most important
"cause of conflict".
Clearly there are many other things
that determine whether or
not a conflict happens.
We are going to try to
isolate the climate component
of these causes.
So again, we're not
being determinists here,
we're just trying to
understand empirically,
is climate an important driver
of observed conflict that we see.
Okay.
And so I wanna be very clear about this.
But it could be an important,
and basically this is an exercise
to try to understand how important it is.
The Defense Department
now talks about climate
as a threat multiplier.
So again, there are many existing threats,
you can see sort of between the aerosphere
and changes in climate might alter
or magnify those threats.
So policy makers are using this language,
and this could have specific implications
for interventions that we might undertake.
If climate is an important cause,
that might change actually
what we do on the ground
to prevent future
conflicts from happening.
So that's why we're gonna study it.
Okay, so what do we
actually know about this?
So it turns out there's actually
a very large literature on this,
and it's really accelerated
in the last decade.
So, with Sol and Ted
almost a decade ago now,
we did what we thought it was
the first sort of empirical meta analysis
of the existing literature.
Back then there was a few dozen studies
and here we're really focused
on the quantitative studies,
studies that used longitudinal
data for the most part
to study empirical relationships
between climate and conflict.
And so this was published, again, in 2013,
and we argued, was the sort
of best empirical summary
of relationships in the literature.
So here, in this study,
and in the update that I'm gonna show you,
we really focused on settings
where we can isolate the impact of climate
from all the other potential
causes of conflict.
And so actually doing this
in a meta analytic way
requires going back to the primary data
in many of these studies,
and reanalyzing them in
what we would think of
as statistically responsible ways.
Using a statistical methodology
that I'll talk about in a second,
that again, can really
isolate the impact of climate
from all the other things that
could be causing conflict.
So the findings from this
earlier meta analysis, again,
the few dozen studies,
we found that increases in temperatures
and an extreme precipitation,
but again, the temperature
signal seemed the strongest,
led to increases in both
interpersonal conflict,
think of this as violent assault,
or homicide, in the worst case outcome.
So two people having an incompatibility
and a larger increase
in inter-group conflict.
So think of this as the
civil complex, civil wars,
that I showed you before.
So robust statistically
significant average relationships
between climate and conflicts
across the studies that exist.
So that was almost 10 years ago now.
There has been an immense
amount of work on this
in the last eight or 10 years
since we published that,
so we want to revisit
this earlier analysis,
we wanna understand
whether our earlier results
still hold up, given the, again,
the large amount that's
been published since.
I think what's interesting
and what made us want to revisit this
is not only that, but that
many new types of conflict
and violence around the
world are being studied.
So I can show you some results on that.
And because we have a lot more literature
and a lot more data,
we have new capabilities and opportunities
to understand the mechanism
linking climate and conflict.
That was not something we
could do a very good job with
in the earlier study.
And of course, that's very important
if we wanna think about interventions.
And finally, again,
we've had a decade with
a lot more conflict
and a decade where we've
seen lots of warming, right?
So you would think it's a decade
where we might be able to
learn a lot empirically
about the relationship
between climate broadly
and conflict.
Okay. So here's what we're
gonna do in this study.
Again, this is mainly a meta analysis,
although we are gonna do some
primary data work as well.
So we are going to update
our earlier meta analysis
on what we will call inter-group conflict,
so again, think of these
as groups fighting groups,
this is civil conflicts of a war,
as well as some other outcomes,
I'll show you in a moment.
So we're gonna distinguish that
from interpersonal conflict,
these are individuals
potentially harming one another,
homicide, violent assault.
We are also going to add in a
third category of self-harm.
And so this is,
you could think of
instead of interpersonal,
intrapersonal conflict.
There's been a lot of
work on that recently,
I'll show you that.
Number three, we're gonna
dive deeper into mechanism
and I'll show you what
we've gotten done on that.
We're far from having a full story here.
I'm gonna look at one potential mechanism
that we can observe and try to measure.
And finally, and I
won't get to this today,
we wanna think about
potential climate impacts,
both in understanding
what climate scientists call attribution,
so what of the existing,
the changes that we've
already observed in conflict,
what can be attributed
to changes in climate,
and second would be a projection
of forward looking thing.
So what might we think
would happen in the future,
given what we've observed
in the recent past,
as temperatures continue to warm.
So I won't do either of those today,
I'll sort of try to set that up,
but that part of the
analysis is not complete.
- Marshall, Marshall,
can I just jump in with a quick question?
- Yeah, please.
- Maybe you're gonna get to this,
but one just thing I wonder,
and I thought about this with
the first slide that you had
with the trend in conflict over time,
just over time, to what extent
does the data that we know
about the increased prevalence of violence
relate to just more comprehensive
and sophisticated ways
of collecting data?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
So one thing you would
very much be worried about
is time trends for various reasons,
but one just a recording
artifact, basically.
We have better data on where
and when conflicts occur,
and so we record more of them over time.
Yeah, that's absolutely right,
and I think that is definitely part
of some of these datasets.
So the way many of these
climate event data sets work
is they scrape basically news reports.
So they look at local news reports,
either from media organizations,
from humanitarian organizations,
and then code these
events as conflicts or not
using existing data that
they can find or estimate
or put together on how
many people were affected.
And it has to be the
case that our information
from local news organizations,
or from humanitarian organizations,
has improved over time
leading to some of that trend.
So we need to be very careful
about that exact problem,
and think about how to control
for the possibility of an
overall secular increase
just due to reporting.
And so in the analysis, and
then I'm gonna show you,
what we can do is try to control
either across all the data,
or in sort of a local way
for any sort of secular, what
we would call, time trends.
Anything else that's driving
trends in conflict over time
that might not be climate,
and again, reporting is one of the things
we're gonna worry about, yeah.
So you're exactly right,
and hopefully we're doing a good job
trying to account for
the reporting part of it.
Okay, so again, this is
a quantitative analysis.
We are not gonna focus on a very large
and important case study in literature,
thinking about conflict.
We are going to focus,
for better or worse,
on quantitative studies that, again,
statistically relate
changes in conflict outcomes
to changes in observed climate.
And in particular,
we are going to focus on studies
that can observe fixed
populations over time
as the climate fluctuates.
So a standard example here, perhaps,
so you might think of, let's
compare Norway to Nigeria.
So Norway is historically
been fairly peaceful,
at least in the past half century,
go back further, less the case,
but thinking in recent era
Norway is fairly peaceful,
Nigeria has unfortunately
experienced a lot of conflict.
Norway tends to be quite cool,
Nigeria is quite hot.
So a naive analysis would say,
you get more conflict where it's hot,
because Nigeria has more
conflict than Norway.
Obviously that's not a great comparison.
We might think that Norway and Nigeria
differ in all sorts of other ways,
other than just their average temperature.
And so that could be a
very confounded comparison.
So we do not include studies
that make those sorts of
cross-sectional comparisons.
Instead, we want to use studies that
don't compare Norway to Nigeria,
but compare Nigeria or some other location
to itself over time,
as it experiences hotter versus cooler
or wetter versus dryer years.
So again, we're going
to use within location
variation over time,
and controlling, as Matt brought up,
for any other thing that could be trending
in a common way across
all units over time.
So if we think this
sort of reporting effect
is sort of similar across
a lot of different units,
let's say all countries in Africa
sort of saw an increase in conflict
just because we're now reporting
on more conflict in Africa.
We're gonna sort of control for that
by accounting for an Africa wide trend,
or an Africa wide year fixed
effect in the parlance here.
So the sort of technology
we're gonna be using here,
the statistical technology
is panel fixed effects regression.
I didn't put up any equations here,
more than happy to go
into the details on this.
And the comparisons that come out of these
are basically the ones
that are on the slide.
There are other things you want
to do in these regressions.
So we're actually gonna
push the data pretty hard.
We want to account for
potential lag effects
of temperature as well.
Those could go in two directions,
it could be the case that
multiple years of
negative climate exposure
increases conflict,
so you want to account for both current
and previous exposure.
It's also the case that
a hot year last year
could've caused a conflict to occur
that was already going to occur anyway.
And that's what we would
think of as displacement.
So if you think there's
potential displacement going on,
and this has actually been well studied
in the heat and mortality literature,
you need to also include lags
of your climate variables.
Again, I didn't wanna go
into too much detail on that,
but happy to talk about the
statistical details there.
In any case, we're running
panel fixed regressions,
we call these distributed lag regressions
where we're including multiple lags
of our climate variables,
and we're adding up
the effects across lags
to generate the overall effect.
That was the only statistical
sort of dive I had there,
again, happy to talk about that more.
Okay. So quickly why meta-analysis,
and then I'll show you
some actual results here.
What can this and what
can't this tell you?
So it cannot tell you
anything about specific conflicts.
So this sort of statistical approach
and the meta-analysis
we're gonna do on top of it
can not tell us that climate
caused the Syrian conflict.
It just can't.
What it can say instead is, on average,
do changing climatic conditions
make conflict more likely.
And again, typically not
individual conflicts.
It has little to say often
about individual conflicts
because the counterfactual,
the unobserved counterfactual
for that conflict
is, again, unobserved.
What it can say is, in
years that are hotter,
drier on average, are you
more likely to see conflicts?
And does that effect differ
as a function of other things we observed?
So that's what we're gonna be able to do.
Okay. So again, the reason for doing this
is we think at least threefold,
this might be able to help us anticipate
the future impacts of climate change.
So there's an important
climate change question here,
and thinking about the overall
cost of climate change,
or how much we should
mitigate climate change,
if increased conflict is a
consequence of a warming climate,
then that's something
we should account for
when we make policy decisions
about how much to mitigate.
It might help us understand
the underlying determinants of conflict.
If we do see large increases
due to climatic changes,
that might help us hone our theories
about why conflicts happen
and what to do about them.
And again, finally, in
the what to do about them
since it might help us
identify interventions
that have at least average benefits,
if not necessarily benefits
for specific conflicts.
Because again, it's gonna be
hard for us to say something
statistically responsible
about specific conflicts.
Okay. So here's our study sample.
So again, we cast a broad net as possible
across many different domains,
so these are papers from economics,
political science, geography,
criminology, anthropology,
marketing science.
So think of this as a very
cross-disciplinary look.
This is months and months
of Google Scholar searching
and tracking down citations of citations.
We include working papers, as you'll see,
we often have to go back
and re-analyze this data,
so we have contacted dozens
and dozens of authors,
requested their data,
if they're willing to share it
or if they're not ready to share it,
we've requested them to
run additional analysis
that we want to see run.
Many have cooperated.
And so the studies that are included
are typically ones where we
can either access the data
or get authors to run the
fixed effects specification
that we want them to run.
So across the different
types of conflicts,
we look at conflict outcomes.
We look at, right now, we
have 68 studies in our sample.
This is likely to grow over time.
And most of these were published
since we did our last analysis.
So 70% of these have
shown up more recently.
Here's the sort of time trend
of when studies in our
sample were published.
So a lot of activity on this
in the last five to 10 years
and on the right is,
I know we're not supposed
to show pie charts,
it's a sort of a dirty pleasure of mine,
I get to show a pie chart.
This is the geographic sample.
So it's really spread
out around the world.
So a lot of our group level conflict
is gonna come from Africa and Asia,
much more of our individual
level conflict observations
is gonna come from wealthier
countries and the OECD.
And we have multiple countries,
sort of 20% of our data,
really take a global look,
so they'll look at more than one,
more than one continent.
Okay. Pause there for a sec.
Hopefully the overall
inclusion criteria are clear.
So again, this is going to
cause us to not look at,
at least in the meta-analysis sense,
a lot of important qualitative work,
thinking about the causes of conflict.
So this is again,
quantitative measurements.
Okay. So initial questions
we're gonna try to answer,
what is the average effect of climate?
And I'm saying that in quotes,
I think about this is warmer temperatures
or more extreme rainfall.
Those are the two main
types of climatic variation
that we're going to be able to look at.
So what is the average
effect of a change in climate
for a given type of conflict?
And again, we're gonna use
those three different groups of conflict.
Number two, do effects
vary across settings?
So you might see point
estimates in different studies
that look different.
Are those truly different,
or are the differences attributable
just to sampling variability,
to statistical noise?
So if we wanna say that
studies are different
and finding different effects,
we need to be able to
differentiate those two things.
True underlying heterogeneity
from sampling variability,
I'll show you some basic
techniques, we used to do that.
And finally, can we understand and predict
why effects vary over settings?
Okay. So again, three
different types of conflicts.
I'm gonna show you three
figures that look like this.
Each line here is a study.
The print here is very small
because we have lots of different studies,
maybe not the best way to show this data.
So each line here is a study,
the solid line is the point
estimate of the effect
from that study,
the relationship between
climate and conflict.
You can see the zero line here
sort of roughly equivalent
to the blue line.
So anything to the left says
warming temperatures are more extreme,
rainfall is reducing the
likelihood of conflict,
anything to the right of
it is saying the opposite,
warming temperatures increase conflict
and more extreme rainfall
increases conflict.
Okay. So this is inter-group conflict.
And again, we've cast a pretty wide net
and dumped a lot of things
into this inter-group bucket.
So we're looking at civil wars,
we're looking at riots,
we're looking at coups,
we're looking at terrorist events,
we're looking at communal,
so non state-based conflict.
And those were sort of listed
along the outcome column here,
if you can see that.
And finally, again,
here are the locations,
so these vary from pretty
small scale locations,
so studies just looking at one
corner of Sub-Saharan Africa
or looking at Syria,
to global level studies
that use country-level
or gridded level data
from around the world.
Okay. So you see the point estimates there
and underlying the point estimates
are the confidence interval.
And so these are bootstrap
confidence intervals
where each little transparent line
is a different re-sample
from that same study.
We are interested in the
statistical uncertainty
for each of these studies,
and so we are going to
basically re-sample the data
from each of these studies
and re-estimate that
effect many, many times.
And so studies where the
confidence intervals are narrow
tend to be ones,
so here's one, if you can see my cursor,
where you see a lot of mass
right around the point estimate.
Many of these other studies,
especially the ones with
very large effect sizes,
turn out to be quite uncertain.
They have large point estimates,
but the confidence
intervals on these studies
are quite large.
And again, I will note that
the estimates shown here
are often not the ones that you would find
in these studies themselves.
We have re-analyzed this data,
and often we come up with
very different answers
than what was in the published paper.
And that's because we are running,
what we are argue, is the
"correct" statistical analysis
for studying this relationship.
So this includes some of
our own earlier studies.
Here's one of mine, Burke et al, 2009.
We had a very statistically
significant result
in that paper that we published,
we have gone back and re-analyzed it,
and it is much less
statistically significant
than what we had published before.
So we're updating our own work as well.
- Marshall, if could just
jump in with another question.
- Yeah, please.
- I kinda see, like, in a generic sense
that doing your panel
fixed effects approach
would be the right way to do this,
with an appropriate data set.
But you said, just sort of
putting that sort of filter
on the previous study, I mean,
presumably judgments were made
when they analyzed the study,
maybe they didn't do the best,
but to what extent are you
kind of like modulating it
for each study,
as opposed to just kind
of everyone has to fit
into your approach.
- Yes.
- Just cause that's very different
from the way you normally
think about a meta-analysis.
- It is.
So there are a lot of research
with degrees of freedom in terms of how
to code the conflict outcome,
how to code the climate exposure.
And so we are letting researchers retain,
or each paper retain a lot
of those researcher choices
about how to code conflict,
what conflict to look at,
what climatic exposure to look at.
All we're doing is saying,
you need to have longitudinal data.
So we've just selected studies
that have longitudinal data
and you need to plausibly account
for confounding variables.
And so we're gonna do that
using some sort of panel
fixed effects analysis.
Most of these studies
are doing some version of that already.
So some of them actually did
not need much alteration.
Often the only thing we're adding
is an adding these sort of lag terms,
that account for displacement
or amplification.
And in some cases, those
weakened the results,
in some cases, they actually
strengthened the results.
So to answer your question, Matt,
we're trying to strike a balance
between preserving a lot of the choices,
the sort of structural
choices the authors made about
what outcome to look at,
what exposure to look at,
and we're just trying to
use the same meta-analysis,
the same statistical sort of framework.
So yeah, you're right
that this is different
than some of the
meta-analysis that you see,
which just take results off the shelf.
They don't worry about necessarily
the statistical analysis
that generated the results.
To us, and especially in this,
having looked at many,
many, many of these studies,
that is a mistake,
because a lot of the variation
for the same dataset,
you can get very different results
if given this sort of statistical
choices you make about
how to run the regression.
And so to us, a better way of doing this
is to keep the regression
that we're running fixed,
and then let authors make choices about
what outcomes to look at,
what exposures to look at.
- Great Marshall, you've
kinda missed a question
in the chat here, too,
it says market indices, EG DJIA,
Shanghai composite, the DE 40 Germany,
are virtually global in scope
to a large degree market activities,
let me see my screen here,
anticipate or reflect issues
concerned with climate change,
conflict, political risk, and more.
Would their inclusion as
factors in your models
potentially add interpretive
value to your results?
- Yeah. Interesting question.
So a lot, if you look at our samples here,
a lot of our samples
and a lot of our data
on group level conflict
comes from an African context,
some from the Asian context,
and at least my experience
working in Sub-Saharan Africa,
is that a lot of these
sort of international
financial aggregates,
their relevance for some of
this rural African context
is potentially limited.
So I'm not sure that
their inclusion would,
and so I guess another
way of putting it is,
and I'll show you in a moment,
if the idea or the concern
is that we need to account
for a local level variation
in let's say economic conditions,
we have more direct ways of doing that,
that we can exploit in
some of these settings.
So we're gonna try and do exactly that,
I think as the comment suggested,
maybe some local data
on economic conditions
could tell us something
about what's going on here.
We're gonna do exactly that.
Thanks.
Okay.
So clearly there's a lot of
spread and point estimates,
so one thing we can do is
just take sort of the average
and here we're gonna take
precision weighted mean,
so what's the mean effect
across all these studies.
We are going to weight,
this is a weighted mean
where studies that are more
precise get higher weight.
This is sort of a standard
approach in meta analysis.
For precipitation, for rainfall,
the precision-weighted
mean is dead on zero.
So it looks like precipitation
sort of on average,
again, on average has no effect.
So we get some negative estimates,
we see some positive estimates,
the precision weighted mean is zero.
For temperature it's not zero.
So we find a precision
weighted effect of about six.
So sorry, here the units are,
to make these studies comparable,
the other thing we have to do
is convert everything into similar units.
The units we use are percentage change
in the conflict outcome
per standard deviation change
in the climatic exposure.
So I think that maybe makes sense
per preset for temperature,
we don't tend to think of temperature
in terms of standard deviations.
So there's that,
but to make it comparable,
we sort of need to use it.
So our average temperature effect
is 6% increase in conflict
for standard deviation
change in temperature.
So if you think a really hot year is a two
or greater standard deviation
increase in temperature,
that means on average, a
really hot year is associated
with 10 to 15% increase in conflict.
So to us that's a meaningful effect.
That's a pretty large effect.
Okay. Again, that's the average effect.
There's a lot of variation.
Let me come back to that
variation in a moment.
That's inter-group conflict,
here's interpersonal conflict.
Here the effects tend to be much smaller,
but much more precisely estimated.
A lot of our data here come
from wealthier countries
where we can put together
pretty detailed data
on interpersonal conflict.
So this is often a violent
crime, murder, assault,
domestic violence, things like that.
And at least in some settings,
these are pretty well measured
in official administrative data.
So here we have about two dozen studies,
about 20 studies, I guess, right now,
25 estimates from almost 20 studies.
Again, effect sizes are smaller,
but they're very precisely estimated.
Most of these appear driven
again by temperature,
which is the best study relationship.
So hotter temperatures increase
the likelihood of interpersonal conflict
and it's about 2% per standard deviation.
So again, a very hot
year or very hot week,
think of it as a two or three
standard deviation event,
and you get a 6% increase
in these different types of conflict.
So again, it's not doubling conflict,
but it's leading to measurable increases
in the occurrence of these
different types of conflict.
So results are actually fairly consistent
for interpersonal conflict.
Finally, for self harm,
and this is the more recent
part of the literature.
So looking at the relationship
between climatic exposure
and in the worst case suicide,
so multiple studies looking at suicide,
including some work that we've done,
in the US and Mexico.
And here again, we see results that look
more or less like the
interpersonal results
in terms of their averages.
So 1% ish increase
in incidents of various types of self harm
or negative mental health issues
per standard deviation
change in temperature.
Okay. And again, smaller
number of studies here,
some variation in the point estimates,
but overall positive relationships.
Okay.
So I'm gonna focus mainly on temperature.
That's where the earlier study,
our earlier meta-analysis
in our studies here
showed a more consistent relationship.
It looks like the mean
effects are positive,
meaningful in a livelihood
or economic sense,
but there's a lot of variation.
And so we first want to understand
whether this variation
is representing true
underlying differences
in the effect sizes across these settings.
Is it true heterogeneity or
is it just sampling variation?
Is it just the fact that
a lot of these estimates are really noisy
and that we can't really say statistically
that the effects are
different across settings?
How do we think about that?
So again, how do we
separate true heterogeneity
from sampling variability?
What we're gonna do here is
estimate hierarchical models.
If folks are familiar with this,
economists have just
gotten excited about these
in the last few years.
So my bias here is,
as someone trained as an economist,
who reads a lot of econ papers,
a couple of really nice
papers, Rachel Meager,
Eva Vivalt, in the last couple of years
have introduced these
techniques to economists,
but they've really existed for a long time
in the statistics literature,
Don Rubin, Andrew Gelman,
and so we're gonna follow their cookbook
on how to do these things.
And basically the idea here is,
and I'm gonna show you a
couple of equations here,
but it's useful for thinking about,
and it's really a nice
way to think about effects
in this or any other meta analysis.
So imagine we have a
bunch of different studies
and each has an estimate
of a treatment effect
you care about.
So here our treatment effect is
the impact of a change in
climate on a conflict outcome.
So each one has an estimate Tk,
and the hat here means it's an estimate.
K next to study, so we have
k studies, 68 studies total.
What we're gonna say in
these hierarchical models
is the effect that we observed,
the Tk that we observed
that is drawn from a distribution
of some true effects,
something that we don't observe,
with some standard error.
So think about there's
the observed effect,
and it is an estimate of
what the true effect is
in that specific setting.
So I'm studying the impact of climate
on conflict in Syria.
I have an estimate from a study
and that's actually a draw
from a distribution around a
true unobserved effect, Tk.
Okay. So that's for each study
and then each study's effect
is drawn from abroad or
distribution of true effects.
And that thing has mean T
and some standard deviation.
Okay. So we have individual studies
with true effects that we don't observe,
and these true effects
are themselves drawn from
this broader distribution.
And so the idea here is you
can write these things down
as normal distributions,
and you can estimate a model
that from the data basically learns
what the true overall average
effect is across the study,
and whether those effects truly differ,
so the Sigma square T thing
is the underlying true variance
in the effects across the studies.
And so you can see the hierarchy.
So this is a two level sort of hierarchy.
You have the individual level estimates,
and then you have this
sort of group level means.
Okay. And basically what
this is gonna tell you,
when you estimate these things,
is that if this variance
is greater than zero,
then there is true
underlying heterogeneity
in your effects.
And that's if it's different than zero,
there's true underlying heterogeneity.
If it's zero, then that
means all the effects
have the same mean,
and that all of the variation
that you see in the point estimates
is just driven by sampling noise
in the sort of first stage,
in the estimation of individual
level treatment effects.
This has a nice mapping
to external validity.
So folks who are used to
thinking about external validity,
you hear this in applied
micro talks all the time.
How does your result in setting A,
what relevance does it
have to new setting B?
That's an external validity question.
Again, the variance tells
you something about that.
If this variance is close to zero,
then that means the true underlying effect
does not differ across settings.
And so you're a study from one setting
has almost perfect external validity
to a study from another setting.
If this thing is large,
if there's true underlying heterogeneity,
then you would be worried
about external validity.
Your study estimate from one setting
is not gonna be necessarily representative
of what you might expect
to find in another study.
This approach gives you a
quantitative way of thinking
about exactly that question.
Okay.
So if the model was right,
and again, you're writing
these things down as normal,
is you gotta take some stands on
sort of what the distributions look like.
There are some nice things
that come out of it.
And again, I think of this as a way
of sort of disciplining our understanding
of whether these effects
are the same or different.
So this first thing is it can tell you
what proportion of the overall
variation effect sizes across studies
is just due to sampling noise.
And that's basically gonna compare
your estimate of the underlying variance
to the study specific standard errors.
So in settings in which
these standard errors are really large
and the underlying
variance is really small,
then you're gonna say
almost all the underlying variation
is just coming from sampling noise.
Versus the setting when
your standard errors
are really tight,
your studies are estimated
really precisely,
but your model says the
underlying variation is large.
There you're gonna say,
look, all that variation
is coming from true
underlying heterogeneity.
Okay. So the model allows
you to estimate that,
and also allows you for each study
to then update your estimate,
to get a posterior estimate
of what the actual effect
in that study is gonna be.
And your estimate,
your best estimate is gonna
be some weighted average
of the thing you actually estimated.
So this is Burke 2009,
the thing we ran before.
So it's a weighted average of that
and our estimate of what
the overall average is,
where the weights are proportional
to how much sampling noise is in my study.
So if my study was garbage
and it was just all sampling noise,
then we're basically gonna
give my study zero weight,
and we're gonna say,
what Marshall should
have found in that paper
is just the average effect across studies.
So again, it gives us a way to think about
not only across the sample,
where's our variation coming from,
but for individual studies,
what was the likely effect
in that individual study,
given all the other studies
that we observed in the dataset?
Finally, it gives you a
best guess as to what,
if you did a new study in a new setting,
what's your estimate gonna
be in that new setting.
So it's a really nice, again,
way to discipline our thinking
about where is variation in
our effect sizes coming from
when we look at a lot
of different estimates
of the same thing.
I won't talk about estimation here,
I point you to the Gelman,
long Gelman chapter
from which we followed to estimate these,
and the recent Meager papers,
if you'd like the econ literature on this,
which are quite clear on this.
Okay.
So we're gonna estimate
these hierarchal models.
Sorry, I switched the notation here.
Different papers use different notations.
So sorry.
μ is now the mean, I
totally screwed this up.
μ is now the mean,
so think of this as the
mean effect across studies,
T is now the standard deviation.
So this is the true underlying mean.
This is the true underlying
standard deviation.
If T is zero,
there is no difference in
true effects across studies.
If T is greater than zero,
there is a difference.
Okay. So focus again on the inter-group.
Our mean is close to
what I showed you before,
so five to six, and again,
this is in percentage point changes
per standard deviation
change in climate exposure.
So a 5% increase in inter-group conflict
per standard deviation
increase in temperature.
So that's the mean, what
I showed you before,
what we would estimate for the model
is this has substantial true
underlying heterogeneity.
We can reject that the
standard deviation is zero,
in fact, it's quite large,
it's almost as large as the mean.
So what this would suggest
is there's a lot of true differences
across the studies,
same thing for interpersonal
and same thing for self-harm.
Although at least for interpersonal,
the underlying variation
is smaller than the mean.
So there we saw sort of
tighter standard errors,
and when you see tighter standard errors
and the effect sizes are
pretty close together,
yeah, you can get sort of tighter
overall distributions here.
So substantial, but across all of these
substantial true underlying heterogeneity,
but at least for inter-group conflict,
it suggests that at over
half of the overall variation
and effect sizes that I showed you
is driven by sampling noise.
So this pooling estimate suggests
that 60% of the differences
are just sampling noise.
Are just a really wide
confidence intervals
that we had on each of those studies.
Less true for interpersonal
and much less true for self-harm,
so this suggests that
actually most of the underlying variation
is coming from true heterogeneity
and not just from sampling variable.
Okay. So what does this tell us?
This tells us that,
of those wide variation
and effect sizes I showed you before,
they are unlikely, completely
driven by sampling variation.
There's likely true
underlying heterogeneity,
and that is particularly true
for interpersonal and self-harm,
it's also perhaps somewhat true
for the inter-group stuff.
As you can see here,
maybe 40% of the remaining variation
is due to true underlying differences.
Okay. The last thing that
this technology can give you,
again, is the updated estimates
for individual studies.
So the black points or
what I showed you before
for inter-group conflict,
individual study level estimates,
the underlying gray line underneath it
is the standard errors on those estimates,
the confidence intervals.
The posterior estimate or
sort of updated estimate
would be in red.
So for this Bohlken and
Sergenti, this first study,
their point estimate was
fairly negative, negative 5%.
Our BASIE model is gonna tell us
actually the true estimate in that setting
is more likely 2%.
So basically the hierarchical model
is going to be very skeptical
here of negative estimates,
negative and particularly
negative noisy estimates.
It's less skeptical of this one,
this has a tight standard error.
But overall it's very
skeptical of noisy estimates,
and it's going to be
quite skeptical of things
that are either quite
negative or quite positive.
And so the term in the literature
for referring to these
are shrunken estimates,
often it's pulling these
estimates towards the mean
and the amount it pulls
them towards the mean
depends on basically how
uncertain the estimates are.
So the more uncertain you are,
the more you get pulled towards mean.
So if this is right then this says
it's actually, most of these settings
were very unlikely to see
the very large estimates
you get in some of these papers,
were very unlikely to see,
unlikely to see large estimates,
unlikely to see negative estimates at all.
So only a few of these remain negative
once we update our priors.
Okay, so.
Matt, just making sure we
go for 20 more minutes?
- I think we go to 3:45.
- 3:45? Okay.
- Yeah.
Marshall, just a question about this.
I mean this sort of shrunken,
I mean, it's by construction, right?
I mean, It's always
gonna turn out that way,
isn't it?
- So there will always be
a little bit of shrinking
unless the standard
errors are literally zero.
So the amount of shrinking
is going to be a function
of how uncertain your estimates are.
So for inter-group conflict,
we have a lot of really noisy estimates,
and so you're gonna
get a lot of shrinkage.
For interpersonal I don't
have that numbers up,
but there we have a lot of
really tight standard errors,
and so when you have a
tight standard error,
the model actually pretty highly weights
your estimate relative to the mean.
- Right. But it's like,
if it's the standard errors
in a study tend to go up
when your coefficient estimate
tends to be further from zero,
it's always gonna shrink it like this.
That's a question, not a statement.
- No, no, no, you're you're right.
But the first part of your question
doesn't necessarily have to be true.
It's true under publication bias,
publication bias story.
But there shouldn't be a
relationship necessarily
between the coefficient estimates
and the size of your standard error.
There often is because
there is publication bias,
but there doesn't need to be.
But you're right, in practice,
there's basically always shrinking,
but the shrinking really is a function
of how noisy each individual estimate is.
So here we see a lot of
study level shrinkage.
- Can I jump in with a quick question?
- Yeah, please.
- I don't wanna get too deep
in the nitty gritty here,
but something I didn't understand is,
are you treating all of these studies
as if they're drawn sort of IID
from that normal distribution?
Are you taking into account
that there could be some dependence
between studies in the same regions
or of the same sub class of violence?
- Yes. That is a very good question.
Not witty at all. Yes.
Right now we are assuming
they are independent,
which is incorrect.
So you can build in a covariance between,
we don't have a good way
of sort of estimating
how independent they are,
I think you're absolutely right
that the assumption of
independence is wrong.
What I think it will do
would be to, in this setting,
lead to further shrinkage, basically.
So it's a little easier to implement
in the precision weighted mean setting
where we can sort of easily assign
a sort of covariance between studies
and then calculate the weighted mean.
Yeah. So you're right.
Right now we are assuming independence
and that's likely not correct.
I think the implication is
it will shrink things more,
but yeah, that's a great point.
- [Student] Thank you.
- Yeah. No, thank you.
It's hard to figure out exactly
how to implement that,
because you gotta take a stand
on what that covariance looks like,
and what, you know,
do you do it based on
number of sort of shared observation,
like how do you do it?
Yeah.
So open to ideas,
if folks have ideas about
the smart way to do that,
we don't have any.
Okay.
So last bit.
So there is true underlying
heterogeneity, let's say,
so that just tells us
studies are different.
It doesn't tell us why
they're different necessarily.
So can we understand
why they're different?
So can we explain or
predict this heterogeneity?
And you could imagine
we could look at this
in different ways.
What I showed you before so far
is the between study differences.
Do we have these estimates
from different studies?
We're getting more and more estimates,
we still don't have that many.
So again, we have a few dozen
for these different types of outcomes.
So you're not super well
powered to understand
potentially many different
sources of heterogeneity,
but that's one way of doing it.
The other way of doing it
is actually looking within studies.
So to the extent within different studies,
we can observe sources of
heterogeneity, moderators.
Within studies you actually might have
a lot more data to do that.
So imagine a lot of
these studies are running
these longitudinal fixed
effects regressions
at a grid cell level.
So you have a grid cell by year,
and Africa might have tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of grid cells.
You might have US counties by year
and have 3,000 counties.
And so in those settings,
you have often very rich data
on moderators of interest.
And so actually you have a lot more data
and a lot more statistical power
to understand heterogeneity.
So we're actually, so far are gonna focus,
and what I'll show you today
is looking within studies,
these studies where we observe
some of the moderators
that we're interested in,
and study whether the effect
of climate on conflict
differs as a function of those moderators.
But we have to do both of these things.
One is just sort of harder
to figure out how to do it
in a statistically powered way.
Okay.
So far I'm only gonna focus
on one potential driver of heterogeneity,
because I'm an economist,
I'm forced to focus on something
about economic conditions
as a key moderator.
So that's what we're gonna do.
This is, of course,
an economist favorite
potential moderator here,
so why might the effect of
climate on conflict differ
across settings?
If you believe that economic conditions
are the thing that links
climate to conflict,
so you get worsening climatic conditions,
these change economic
conditions on the ground,
and these induce individuals
to start or join conflict,
so that's the typical story
that you will often see in
the economics literature.
It's a story about opportunity costs.
So a worsening climate
reduces the opportunity cost
of joining a conflict.
You need to put food,
put in like normal words,
you need to put food on the table.
Your crops have failed.
This might be the only way to do it.
These conflicts actually typically start
with a very small number of people.
So this doesn't have to turn
every single farmer into a fighter.
It just needs to turn a few dozen of them
into such a thing or have
hundreds join a conflict.
So just, you need a few at the margin
to make this decision.
That's the argument.
So again, I think there's some
reasonably strong evidence
of that this is one plausible channel,
at least in the economics literature.
You've also seen it in the
individual level conflict.
So it could be the case that
tough economic conditions
in a city or a location
could make individual
level conflict more likely
when there's, again,
some sort of downturn or
some sort of triggering event
brought on by the climate
or by something else.
I would say overall that
this sort of hypothesis
is consistent with the conventional wisdom
you often see in the
climate impacts literature.
This is that there's something
insulating about wealth.
Wealthier populations
are somehow less effected
by changes in climate.
I would say this is a
strong conventional wisdom
that you see all the time.
I think people, again,
have different stories
about why this might be the case.
People can afford to
undertake protective behavior.
They work in sectors that
are just fundamentally
less effected by changes
in climate anyway.
But again, you see various
flavors of this all the time.
So all of these would predict overall
that you see a basic heterogeneity
as a function of economic
conditions on the ground.
So in wealthier locations,
you should see less relationship
between climate and conflict.
And on some level,
I think we already know this to be true.
We have not seen, thank goodness,
civil conflicts or civil wars
in most wealthy countries in centuries.
So if I were to estimate the
relationship between climate
and civil conflict in
most wealthy countries,
I would get a zero, right?
Because we do not observe civil
conflict in those countries.
So variation in climate,
which we have seen,
has not induced conflict of that sort.
So on some level, this has to be true.
We are going to try to estimate
on a more local level,
whether it's true in
settings that we care about.
Okay.
- Hey, Marshall, I don't
wanna affect your flow here.
- No, no, please.
- You haven't been able to
see in some of the chats,
but you got a question in here,
another question, it says,
this is from Thomas B and he says,
the linearly vertical
shape of the posterior
shows both lack of fit
as well as virtually constant estimates.
To me, this suggests revisiting
the model assumptions,
e.g the distribution of normal errors,
a different distributional
assumption, e.g the YBo
or the Cauchy might be worth testing.
- Yeah. I think that's fair.
Yeah.
There's some choices you can make
in the model and Cauchy.
So the way you, yeah.
You have to make assumptions or choices
about what sort of distributions
you assume about the errors,
and yeah, I think you're right that,
that normal might not
be the best choice here.
Yeah. It's a great point.
I'm not sure that what I showed
is necessarily indicative of poor fit.
I think what it's indicative of,
is given those assumptions that,
and given the large statistical noise,
large confidence intervals
we see in a lot of these studies,
we shouldn't be surprised
that a lot of those get
pulled in towards the mean.
Just because they're highly uncertain.
But I think you're right
that we should explore
whether those results change
if we change our assumptions
about the underlying distribution,
I think that's totally right.
Thanks.
Okay.
So we're gonna do this
in three different settings right now,
we're working on expanding this right now.
This is actually some
primary data analysis.
So to make sure we can do
this in a consistent way,
we've gone back and reanalyzed
gridded data across Sub-Saharan Africa
over the last three decades.
This is again, those data from UCDP
that I showed you before.
So this is gridded level,
civil conflict data.
The grid size here is
like a 50 kilometer grid.
So these are geo referenced
conflict event data.
So we're gonna look at that
as our group level conflict outcome,
and we're gonna look at homicide
and violent crime in the US
as our individual level outcomes.
And again, we're gonna try to estimate
whether the effect sizes,
the marginal effects,
so the additional effect
of an increase in climate
on a conflict outcome,
either civil conflict or
violent crime in the US,
whether that differs as a
function of local level income,
which we observe in the US,
or local level asset wealth,
which is the sort of
economic characteristic
that we observe in Sub-Saharan Africa.
So the county income level,
county level income data is
just admin data in the US.
In a place like Sub-Saharan Africa,
we often don't have comprehensive
data on these outcomes.
So the data we are going to use
comes from a whole different
set of projects that I work on,
which is a remote sensing,
machine learning based approach
to estimating local level livelihoods
around the world,
including in Sub-Saharan Africa.
Happy to talk more about this,
we have a bunch of papers on this.
Here's one that we're gonna
use directly from last year
led by some great students.
And basically here we're going
to take existing level data
on economic characteristics on the ground.
This could be local level asset wealth.
So think of asset wealth
as a summary index
of the assets that you own,
TVs, cars, radio, cell
phones, your roof type,
what your house is made of,
whether you have electricity.
We basically create an index out of that
and happy to talk more about that,
that index tends to be pretty robust
to what we throw in it.
Ownership of assets tends
to be highly correlated.
And so we have some surveys
where we observe that,
and then we're gonna train a model
to actually predict that
from various sources
of daytime and nighttime
satellite imagery.
And what we show in this paper
and another paper is that,
that does a lot better
than some of the things you see
in the econ literature pretty prominently,
just using nighttime lights imagery.
So there's a lot of issues
with nighttime lights.
And it turns out using
that in combination with
daytime multi-spectral satellite imagery,
lets you do a very good job
of predicting variation in asset wealth.
So here I'm showing you
a figure from this paper.
This is Nigeria.
We've done this now for
all of Sub-Saharan Africa
back to about 2003.
So we have annual estimates
of very local level asset wealth
across Sub-Saharan Africa
for the last two decades.
And so that's gonna be
our sort of economic measure
that we're gonna use as a source
of potential heterogeneity
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
So again, happy to talk
more about this dataset,
but that's what we're gonna be using.
Okay. So here's the three
different heterogeneity analysis.
I am looking at the time.
This is last empirical slide.
So we see strong,
so this is just run as
a linear interaction
what I'm showing you here.
We can do this non-linearly
and it gets a little bit noisier,
but the overall sort of slope is the same.
Basically at low levels of income,
we can be quite confident
that the relationship
is large and positive
for civil conflict in Sub-Saharan Africa.
So this is low levels of asset wealth.
For homicide in the US
and for violent crime in the US.
So I have bootstrapped this
regression a bunch of times,
each line here is a different bootstrap.
So I think I ran it a thousand times
for each of these.
So it gives you a sort of a
sense of the visual uncertainty,
the dark line, if you can see it,
is the overall sort of median estimate
across those bootstraps.
So the estimates at higher wealth index,
at higher income levels,
tend to be not statistically significant.
So again, strong, positive effects
at low parts of the asset
or income distribution,
and then effects then decline towards zero
at higher incomes or higher
levels of asset wealth
across both individual level conflicts,
again, homicide, violent crime,
and civil conflict in Africa.
So this is not a meta
analysis of existing studies,
this is now we're using data
that had been used in those studies
and we're doing this ourselves.
This is consistent with some
great country-level work.
So there's a couple studies out there,
a very nice study by Teevrat
Garg and colleagues in Mexico,
by Thiemo Fetzer in India,
that leverage various policy experiments
to show that, as in the Indian case,
workfare that, NREGA program,
was rolled out across India,
this broke the link between
climate and conflict.
So sort of a direct test of
the income hypothesis here.
Similarly PROGRESA in Mexico
villages or localities
that got PROGRESA saw less conflict
as temperatures increased.
So think of these results
as consistent with the few other existing,
very nice quasi-experimental
papers in the literature.
So it looks like we do see
strong heterogeneity by income.
Now I think we should be a little cautious
about these results,
because income could be
correlated with other things
that are driving this heterogeneity.
So we are not going to
have perfect designs
to be able to isolate the impact of income
from other things correlated with income.
Teevrat and Thiemo and colleagues,
their designs, I think, are
gonna be a little bit nicer
than these sort of
cross-sectional interactions
we have here.
But again, overall, it's consistent
with what the literature
seems to be saying here.
Okay. Let me just finish it up quickly.
So implications for future conflict.
So hopefully I've convinced
you that looking backwards,
at least in some settings,
we see pretty substantial relationships
between warming in particular
and various types of conflict,
but that this effect might differ
as a function of economic conditions,
average economic conditions on the ground.
And so effects seem to be
amplified in lower income,
lower wealth communities,
either in Sub-Saharan Africa or in the US.
Okay. So what do we have
coming down the pipe?
So we have a lot of warming,
as folks might know,
we remade this sort of standard,
how much is the world gonna warm up map
in terms of standard deviations,
cause that's how we've done the analysis.
And especially in the tropics,
so this is the projected
temperature increase by 2050
in standard deviations.
This is a plot we made a few years ago.
It's probably a little
bit higher right now.
Temperature projections
have come down a little bit,
thank goodness.
But basically what you
see in the tropics is,
been to the tropics or from the tropics,
you know the temperature
just doesn't vary that much.
The year to year variation is quite small,
and so a degree or two
increase in temperature
is a huge increase in terms
of standard deviations.
It could be up to a forth
standard deviation
increase in temperature.
Given historical variability,
that's just really tightened the tropics.
So in terms of standard deviations,
we expect massive increases
across the tropics,
and much lower increases in
the much higher latitudes
where the year to year
variability, historically,
has been quite large.
So even though you're
gonna see more warming
in the higher latitudes in
terms of standard deviations,
it's actually smaller.
Okay.
So if you believe the recent past
can be a guide for the future,
this would suggest
we have a lot of warming
coming down the pipe.
Warming's rapidly gonna push
societies and the tropics
beyond what they've
experienced historically.
And so we might think that
could exacerbate conflict risk,
but pushing back the other way is,
perhaps what I just showed you, right?
If there is income heterogeneity,
if we think that rising incomes
could help break the link
between climate and conflict,
if development continues in the future,
as it has in the recent past,
then maybe that's a force
pushing the other way.
You have warming pushing in one direction
and you have development
pushing in another direction.
So here's a map I just made quickly
of the African asset wealth data we have,
this is now aggregated to admin two level,
but this is basically the growth
in asset wealth over time,
is estimated from satellites.
A lot of places are growing really fast.
You have many parts of east Africa,
parts of west Africa that are growing
at 0.2 standard deviations per decade,
which is really impressive growth.
So these places are developing quickly
and our estimates would
suggest that that's going to,
again, reduce the likelihood
that a negative climate event
triggers a conflict outcome.
Okay.
So as these two forces sort
of pushing against each other,
as we go forward here,
our goal is to try to say
something quantitative
about those two forces
and what the overall effects
might look like in the future.
That's not ready for public
consumption yet today.
So I'll just, I'll leave
you with these maps.
So let me wrap up here.
Again, I would say fairly
consistent evidence
of higher temperatures can
contribute, not always,
but can contribute to conflict risk.
Again, we see this
across many different geographic settings,
many different types of conflicts.
And I would say the overall
strength of this evidence
has grown a little bit
since the last study.
Our average effects are
maybe a bit smaller,
but we have a lot more evidence
saying that they're there.
I think these effect sizes are meaningful.
So a five to 10% increase or 5% increase
per standard deviation is large,
especially if you think
that future climate change
is going to lead to a mini
standard deviation increase
in temperature exposure.
So a naive multiplication
of those two things
would suggest large increases in conflict,
but again, pushing the other
way is economic development.
And so to me, this is at
least somewhat comforting,
the fact that economic development
and the various things that that brings
can help break the link
between climate and conflict.
We see some evidence that that's the case.
So really it's gonna be sort
of a horse race, unfortunately,
between a warming climate,
and hopefully developing economies
and with, I would say, a
sort of unknown net impact
that we're gonna try to estimate.
So I will stop there. Thanks
a lot for your comments.
I have a couple more minutes
and happy to hear more
comments or questions,
and appreciate the attendance.
Thanks.
- Thanks, Marshall.
Anybody who has any comments or questions,
feel free to just unmute
yourself and jump in.
- I have a question,
Marshall, if you don't mind.
- Yeah, please.
- I was wondering if you could do
some of those plots of
the study effect sizes
as scatterplots,
with either precision
or the power of the study on the y-axis.
It might be interesting to see
if there's like a discontinuity near zero
that would suggest that there's
some file drawer problem
or selection publication bias
and which studies are
actually being put out there.
- Yeah. Thanks.
That's a great idea.
I think it would be a nice way
to just look at the effects overall,
as a sort of one way of
thinking about publication bias.
I mean, what's funny is,
I think that's especially a useful way
of thinking about the existing estimates
that are in the published studies.
We think studies might be
selected on those estimates.
Often our re-analysis
leads to estimates that
are quite different
than what's in the published papers.
So I think there would be less
chance for publication bias
in sort of our re-estimates,
just because of the fact that
those were not often
the published estimates.
But I think you're right,
there are a bunch of approaches
for thinking about publication bias
and the importance of publication bias,
or the existing of publication bias
in these meta-analysis, and yeah.
So we need to do more of that.
Yeah. Thanks.
- Anybody else?
Well, thanks, Marshall.
Very interesting.
I think the room here,
the weather here
has probably scared people
from the room, I see,
but you got many interested folks online
and obviously an important
and interesting topic,
and so I thank you on
behalf of all the others
for an interesting seminar,
we look forward to the future results
that you have coming down the line.
- All right. Thanks, Matt.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks everybody for coming.
- Take care. Bye bye, everybody.
- [Marshall] Take care. Bye.